okay
foreign
foreign
Obama
if there is anything that needs to be
satirized and remixed it is Trump
talking about massive dumps and by the
way extra points if you can sample Trump
saying massive dumps and me talking
about it in a song please do it
[Music]
big massive dumps
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what is going on here what is go what is
going on here
it's just beyond parody a massive dumps
cost of the election
what is going on here
I'm worried about my espresso machine
it's not a joke it's just I'm worried
about my lathe
up there like and I'm here
[Music]
who broke into my computer for the back
end data just exploded I'm talking about
getting rid of the machine felt him down
and turned him into prison by his pillow
I'm not a lawyer the lawyers are lawyers
the lawyers are lawyers the lawyers are
lawyers get rid of the machine I'm
trying for getting rid of the machines
just pillows who did this attack who did
this Cyber attack so you have you know
the good Geeks and they patch it up and
they fix it and they put up better
protection virus protection but here's
what my attorney said he said um
[Music]
do you frequently go to Hardee's is that
a common place you go okay that's pretty
funny David no exactly
that could be your headline the machine
I said I would have passed through on
the lid to find a ride through it's
really incredible The Branding around
that she said no you're not getting my
phone I said arrest me I've done nothing
wrong he said no we're not gonna arrest
you I so you can do anything you have to
and you can do it you can do okay
get rid of the machine I've tried from
getting rid of the machine I'm worried
about my pillow no no dude that's the
worst thing for you because your
cervical nerves in your neck I will send
you some pillows I'm worried about my
legs I'm sorry about getting rid of the
machines Okay Melt them down and turn
them into prison bars
pillow all right thanks Mike Take Care
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
la la la la la
[Music]
la la la
[Music]
well it's a very special day because we
have today returning to the program Mike
Lindell CEO and inventor of my pillow
what what would you like me to say David
[Music]
I'm not a lawyer the lawyers are lawyers
what's so hard to understand
they can pull these names it's just like
every state every state has people that
voted that don't live in the states
I have a moral compass two million you
can get them I did I got requests out to
every single these are right on the
voter rolls David you're not listening
but you're not listening
[Music]
get rid of my espresso machine the
voting machine David everything can be
capped you got you know credit cards
companies get hacked businesses act gas
companies act who did this attack who
did this Cyber attack that's all I'm
about we can't have computers running
our election Mike you've mentioned so
much let me just make one comment here
nope nope nope melt them down and turn
them into prison bars
again
when you have a computer you can change
one number you can do anything you hack
in and you can expect Millions where if
you had to do the same thing with paper
you'd have to have a ball of people you
asked me the dumb question about getting
rid of machines if you want to be a
humorous interview get rid of my
espresso machine
[Applause]
[Music]
Aaron Brown
but I'm not a lawyer the lawyers are
lawyers
I'm not a lawyer the lawyers are lawyers
[Music]
you should have one of my pillows too we
are gonna take a moment to recover here
from the extremely high level of energy
I concoct you all day about this
well welcome everybody it is so good to
finally be back it has been seven weeks
almost to the day I'm actually making
that up it's been roughly seven weeks
but it's better to say to the day uh
since the last stream and so much has
happened and it is so absolutely
fantastic to be here we are on
indictment watch for Donald Trump the
Georgia grand jury has finished its work
and the indictment could come in quite
literally any moment or never those are
sort of the bounds of the possibility a
second from now to there will never be
an indictment it is somewhere in that
range and we are watching it very
closely now many of you asking sir
a lot of big strong guys in fact coming
to me uh the other day at Trader Joe's
and also in saying certain with tears
why haven't you been streaming and there
are many many many many many many many
many many many many reasons
um so we we had the Thanksgiving
holiday
directly into moving directly into the
entire household getting the virus
directly into the New Year's break and
still trying to finish everything here
at the new studio now you might say you
know David I'm looking around it it sort
of looks like the old Studio but let me
show you why it is not
see that right there
everybody see what's happening right
we filmed the empty old Studio
and we are now using that on a green
screen
and soon the new studio will be unveiled
okay so boom I'm in the studio ding I'm
away from the studio the only element
that is missing here
is I need a better backlight uh let me
see if I can show you
hold on a second let me see if I can
move out of the way here
see that see this thing I'm using an
Elgato key light air as my backlight
it's too diffused quite frankly it's
unprofessional
and um I need a better backlight and
what I would like to do is actually
Mount the backlight
either to the crossbar on the green
screen or I don't know what to do so if
people have any suggestions for an
actual good backlight that would give me
what I need because this see my hair is
looking way darker basically okay we've
been working on the audio the sound
dampening is much better the entire room
is basically covered in acoustic foam
it's all improving it's all improving
okay so I'm glad to be back and
streaming and so many important
different things are going on the town
hall is tonight at the top of the hour
okay so everybody here for the town hall
it's in 40 minutes everybody's going to
be allowed to call in it's going to be
an amazing wonderful delightful
beautiful thing and I really do look
forward to it and we are really
rebuilding 2023 is going to be a
rebuilding year the end of 22 was tough
as many of you know
um a lot of different things going on uh
the not streaming also really really
really crushes you as you can see over
my head it's like when you put water on
cotton candy and it just evaporates the
twitch Subs have completely evaporated
it's all insane so I appreciate the 12
now actually 14 people who have just
re-upped their twitch Prime
subscriptions and by the way thank you
to the people who even though I didn't
stream last month re-upped their twitch
Prime subscriptions keeping an
uninterest uninterrupted flow of 40
consecutive months which is insane I
have so many things we're going to go
over but I have to say first and
foremost we as a community
and I include you uh in that Community
we have an important moral decision to
make oh hold on we have our first super
chats that song at the beginning are you
and Donald going on tour sometime soon
would like to see you perform live oh
let actually let me address that so I
have my notes Here I addressed where
I've been and having having the virus
talked about that
um
okay I have three upcoming appearances
now as many of you know I am very very
hesitant to announce forthcoming
appearances because things so often get
canceled things so often get rescheduled
sometimes it takes a very very long time
okay but it's so exciting what is going
on that I feel
unable to resist telling you what is
coming up
I am about to be doing the following
three appearances in different parts of
the world I will be on with Lex Friedman
a very powerful YouTuber and podcaster
over two and a half million YouTube
subscribers many many many many many
many many many many many many many many
podcast subscribers Etc it will be a
long form conversation it will be long
and it will be wide I expect Lex
Friedman appearance coming up very very
soon secondly I will be on with Patrick
Bet David who recently uh sort of
debated I guess you would say Neil
deGrasse Tyson about vaccines
um etc etc I will be on with Patrick Bet
David that will be in Florida
um and I will also be on with Anthony
pompliano in Florida so one of those
appearances in Florida the other in
Florida it'll be very very important
um and all of this will be happening
between now and February 1st of course
unless it gets canceled and or I end up
with covet again or you know all the
normal things and this is why I am so
hesitant to announce appearances ahead
of time but I think it's going to be
really really good I think it's going to
move the needle for the show I think
it's going to be an incredible thing
incredible incredible thing uh okay
appearances I have mentioned them let me
close that out okay I want to mention
that there is soon going to be a Purge
of sorts coming to our Discord we have a
system in our Discord
where
you can get verified as a website member
at joinpakman.com in fact that will be a
requirement if you want to get Priority
Access during today's Town Hall after
today's Town Hall we are purging all
website member roles on the Discord and
we are restarting why because over time
people who are no longer members have
kept the member role on Discord that's
not fair to the real members and that's
not fair to the non-members and we're
not going to have it okay so
unfortunately sometimes you've got to
wipe the Slate clean and there will be a
Purge after today's Town Hall
all website member roles on the Discord
will be cleared and then we are going to
start from scratch okay very very
important and I hope people aren't upset
about it in terms of new visual elements
this is the last thing and then we're
going to get on to the contact to the
content for the show in terms of visual
elements that I could use your your help
with a new start screen would be really
good the new start screen or the old
start screen that we currently use which
I'll put up in a moment still mentions a
coupon code from 2021 take a look at
this
foreign
so if somebody wants to design a new
start screen that would be really really
great and the other thing is we are
ready for our new live stream overlays
particularly once the new studio is up
and running and we've got that big
rectangular blue box at the top that's
not used the old logo is down there you
know all these different things if
someone wants to design some new um
overlays please get in touch info
davidpackman.com and I will say last
time people wrote to me who had never
done overlays before and some of them
sent me like bitmaps that were created
in paint and it's like it I really
appreciate everybody's want interest in
helping but please only get in contact
if you actually have experience doing it
because I don't I don't want to waste
your time and I don't want to waste my
time both are very precious I respect
your time too much to consider wasting
it okay so that's the other announcement
all right let's get into some of the
content we have a very important
decision to make my friends and it has
to do with the mango song you may have
learned and we talked about it on the
podcast today that diamond of diamond
and silk has passed away it appears as
though it was from covid but it's not
completely clear at this point in time
we have two options you might have
noticed I did not play the mango song
during the introduction today there are
two views on this one is we should
eliminate and retire the song because of
it would be disrespectful to the memory
of diamond to keep playing it the
Counterpoint to it would be that it is
sort of a tribute in a sense to Diamond
okay so I'm going to play the song while
we play it we will get polls going on
Instagram on where am I talking about on
on Twitch and on YouTube and people can
vote as to whether we should keep it
let's take a look
mangoes
I love mangoes too
now cause
[Music]
11.99 that seems like a pretty good deal
a bag of mangoes mango art mangoes
that's it eight or eleven bucks
[Music]
all right
[Music]
the Wisconsin crowd identified with the
mango material
we affected the American people
don't want me to me
it's highway robbery is what you doing
[Music]
so there it is folks the question of
course is do we keep the song or do we
get rid of it on YouTube the results are
by a roughly two to one margin the
YouTube audience says keep don't retire
the song over on Twitch by a similar
margin 70 30 the twitch audience says
keep the song I believe the audience has
spoken and out of respect and as a
tribute to Diamond we will keep the song
we will keep the song ladies and
gentlemen all right so the audience has
spoken and I believe that that is
absolutely fair I want to say thank you
to Jason sickmeyer for gifting a
subscription on my website also thanks
to physicist Mike blades deeper shades
of house and guitar goddess for their
twitch subscriptions I really appreciate
that all right let's get on to oh oh oh
oh hold on a second
I haven't just been twiddling my thumbs
taking care of a baby in the last seven
weeks before uh since the last stream
by your demand we are almost ready to
launch a feature that you requested many
of you of course are familiar with my
soundboard right you know about the
sound board deal that included the
largest agricultural
right Obama over 54 countries have now
been taken by the machines and we will
ban men globalist okay everybody knows
that
you asked that we develop a soundboard
with our drops and make it available to
our members
I am 95 of the way to launching exactly
that feature I think people are really
going to like this we this is what it
will look like we're still it's got to
be modified a little bit this is going
to be in the member section launching
very very soon okay you're going to be
able to use this I'm not going to give
people ideas but let's just say it might
be useful for phone calls it might be
there's a whole bunch of different ways
that people might want this okay this is
the way it'll work
essential Donald Trump yeah Donald Trump
no more
a rhino named Mitt Romney okay this is
about to launch and so all of you
members who have been asking for this
feature for a very long time you're
about to get it we're going to be
launching this very very soon and it'll
be available on the website I think it's
going to be a really really great thing
and
um more information about that out soon
okay very good let's continue looking at
some other things that have been uh
going on I just want to kind of take it
take a look at different things Mike
pillow has resurfaced after claiming to
have evidence of fraud in the 2020
election and never presenting it pillow
is now moving on to Brazil where he says
he have evidence he has evidence of
fraud there as well take a listen to
this would you volunteer to actually go
to Brazil and present all the
information you have to Lula of Brazil
would you go down there fly down there
and make yourself available to present
everything you know about the machines
and everything you've learned about the
machines to try to sort that situation
outside sort it out well not not me
personally because I've heard about this
Lula guy I uh and I've got uh but I have
I have actually people that have already
volunteered to go down there if need be
and they can do a lot better presenting
this so they've already told them uh
we've already reached out to Brazil and
said hey if you want honest we're
available so we'll see what happens if
you want to Avail yourself of Mike
pillows Services where he will tell you
all of the different ways in which there
was fraud he is willing to go down there
he doesn't want to do it but he's
willing to send delegates
you hold a hang on your breaking news
here you've actually reached out to the
authorities there and say that you guys
your team the authorities like who has
he reached out to of the technical
people and all your people are available
to go down and actually brief them
yeah absolutely we have that's breaking
news Steve Bannon is uh it's incredible
how much news is broken on Steve
bannon's program Mike pillow is it's
pretty generous to say that that's
breaking news yeah exactly Jeremy Ranch
saying that's a pretty generous term
um breaking is doing a lot of heavy
lifting in that so anyway if they want
him down there you know I actually think
they should bring the inventor of the
machines down to Brazil George Santos to
really explain to everybody
um how all of that how all of that works
very very important here's a video we
looked at on today's podcast but I
always welcome an opportunity uh to
watch Insanity a second time this is at
a turning point USA event this young
lady was asked DeSantis or Trump and she
feels very strongly about DeSantis
listen to this Trump or DeSantis
DeSantis all day why well because I
don't like vaccine salesmen and uh
millions of people are being killed all
across the world and I blame Donald
Trump for that yeah
um millions of people are are are dying
around the world for all sorts of
different reasons but the covid vaccine
is not one of those reasons and of
course there is no evidence of that in
the United States we have a system
called vayers it's the vaccine adverse
event reporting system
and anybody can submit whatever the hell
they want to it and if you die of a car
accident 10 months after getting
vaccinated that can end up on vayers and
count as what this young lady calls a
vaccine death
um so this stuff continues to be to
float around I I mentioned 15 minutes
ago I did see Neil deGrasse Tyson try to
talk to Patrick Bet David about vaccines
I'm going to be on with Patrick Bet
David in a couple weeks maybe the topic
of vaccines will come up I don't know
um but it I always welcome the
opportunity to talk you know one of the
things with a lot of these people is
they'll it's not it's you you have to
establish what question they're trying
to answer and what I mean by that is
some people will say the we gotta we
gotta stop with the vaccine stuff
because it's just crazy
and you go well what's crazy
do you believe vaccines as a technology
don't work or do you believe that
mandates which basically don't exist are
against the law or like what is it
exactly that you're trying to answer and
often they don't know there's like it's
just crazy they want you to woke vaccine
yourself into Oblivion it's like okay
hold on a second that's that that's not
really substantive let's back it up a
little bit uh let's figure out exactly
what question you want to answer and
very often they have no idea
they have no clue whatsoever and this is
where you often get this it's kind of
like the verbal ink blot where they jump
from one thing to another when trying to
make an argument I once was in a crate
this this was actually kind of
unfortunate
um in
um
um what year was it a few years ago it
was actually
I actually think it was when uh hold on
was Trump yeah it was at the very
beginning no it was during Obama's
presidency Obama yeah where I we ran
into at like a party a dinner party
um someone that my girlfriend went to
high school with and it turns out that
his family is like a big Republican
family and I had no idea
and all of a sudden
he just when it comes up like what I do
this guy just drops out of nowhere yeah
well I hate to say it but you and the
liberal media really screwed us because
now we're really now we're screwed you
know it's like Mitt Romney could be the
president right now but you guys really
screwed us I'm sorry I'm sorry but you
screwed us and I go oh okay well
in what way are things worse now with
Obama rather than Romney and the guy's
like just he's destroyed the economy oh
but by what metric
uh with just everything's terrible oh
really okay because unemployment's low
and stock market's doing fine and
inflation's low and then and then he
goes Obama said there was a red line in
Syria though and now he didn't do
anything and I go well your first thing
was that the economy would be better
under Romney than under Obama and when
we dug into that now you're talking
about a red line in Syria now we're now
we're on foreign policy they don't know
what's going on
they just have no idea what's going on
and the guy ended up leaving without
even saying bye to my girlfriend even
though they've like knew each other for
20 years it was weird never spoke to the
guy again sad story sad story but my
life is probably better never seeing
that guy again if I'm totally honest uh
okay thanks to Emily Bernie and Billy
for the twitch Prime subscriptions I
really appreciate that speaking of
critical thinking this is actually a
serious thing and I think people are
going to like this many of you know
that I have been arguing for a decade
that we must start teaching critical
thinking
earlier than we currently do
if at all right some people never get a
critical thinking glass ever and if they
don't go to college they may never get
it in their lives then all of a sudden
they go Fox News is the only one that
tells the truth and then you you know
that's how 74 million people end up
voting for Trump
I am putting my money where my mouth is
on this issue
as I have said many times before
we must in the U.S yes I know I know
people from Sweden are in the chat going
we what do you mean we I mean we in the
U.S yeah
uh we are very very soon going to be
releasing
hey oh hold on a second look at this
someone says that teaching critical
thinking is liberal indoctrination
no no no no no no no no
we are very close to completing a
children's book on critical thinking
this is going to be an illustrated book
that is meant to get six to
eight-year-olds thinking about things
like
what can we learn from asking questions
what's the difference between the truth
and a lie
how do you know if someone's telling the
truth
it is going to be the absolute Basics
okay there's a lot of people that write
to me and they say David I have kids
they're gonna go into school
they're not going to be taught this
stuff what can I do and I go well you
got to just start talking to them about
some of this stuff
we're going to be publishing a a book
meant for children to start introducing
them to critical thinking it's not going
to be politically biased in any way it's
not going to address political issues
it's just going to be about how we learn
things how we know things how we ask
questions how to think a little bit I
think this is maybe one of the most
important things that we will have ever
done I'll tell you guys more about it
later I I want to do it paperback and
Kindle
paperback is tougher the book's been
banned by DeSantis I know yeah it's not
even out it's already been banned
um I want to do paperback and Kindle
I'll have more information for people
soon it's another thing that we've been
working on so many so many different
things all right let's continue on with
what we have here thanks to Bert as well
as crowbars for the twitch Prime
subscription top of the hour in 20
minutes will be the David Pacman show
Town Hall
um and I look forward to hearing from
many of you this is maybe the most
insane thing I've ever seen on Newsmax
and we've seen a lot of really really
crazy things on Newsmax listen to Eric
bowling here but what's frightening
these so-called journalists at New York
Times influencers and media and academic
circles they feel empowered to lecture
you about your love interests who you
should marry and have children with this
is the road to tyranny isn't it and the
next thing you know will have a one
child policy just like China did until
it doesn't work anymore okay sure I'll
give them this shorter people do tend to
live longer on average but you know what
else there's this according to a study
shorter men tend to have more
Psychopathic traits this is a segment on
a supposed News Channel these really
really anti-milk Pro soy anti-beef
eating liberals want you to mate with
potential Psychopaths
how is that how is that how about that
line these really anti-milk pro-soy
anti-beefeeding liberals want you to
mate with potential Psychopaths
extraordinarily valuable news huh
literally little Mad Men that's wild
enough the arrogance to even suggest
such a thing that's not very feminist
either is it and definitely not
pro-woman this is this is funnier than
SNL SNL can't possibly do a parody of
this because this is the parody so it
got me thinking some of the most violent
look at this disturbing and even by the
way how stupid is it to have Hillary
Clinton listed as a short person at five
six when that's taller than the average
height of women isn't it
average height of American women I
thought it was 5'4 it is this this is
also so stupid the average woman is 5'4
and he wants to make the argument that
at 5'6 Hillary Clinton is on a list of
particularly short people she's tall for
being female and born in the United
States
even at the at the basic level it's
stupidity knowing people in history were
actually quite short let's go through
just a few shall we please occult leader
Charles Manson five foot six inches
convicted of first-degree murder among
many other things all right you see how
this is going
I don't even know how he doesn't get
fired after this this is absolutely
humiliating absolutely humiliating oh
let me get to some super chats folks I
apologize okay omagaya says hey David
did you see any of the latest Jordan
Peterson meltdown last week he's in
danger of losing his license in Ontario
and told lies about it on Twitter I saw
it but I don't really know what's going
on it's sort of sad but Jordan Peterson
really has lost his mind
and it's it's it it is a very very sad
thing David says Stephen Colbert said it
best we should call Kevin McCarthy the
squeaker of the house not bad
not bad
Dominic's a serious question will I be
able to purchase the book in bulk my
partner and I have been wondering what
we can do in donating these to Local
Schools sounds like a great idea
absolutely when we release the critical
thinking for kids book you know Matt
Walsh released an anti-trans book and
it's not even worthy of being used as
toilet paper okay we are going to put
together something of value here and it
would be an amazing thing to dump
massively onto schools that lack
critical thinking classes we can talk
about that uh people asking what
happened to my hair nothing what do you
mean
um I explained the I the the lighting
we're in a new studio the lighting is
not yet perfect that's what happened and
soon it's going to be it's gonna be good
okay so everybody relax
uh Christy says thanks for encouraging
critical thinking love the show thank
you Chrissy
in tune Knitter says will children want
to transition on account of your having
your critical thinking book read to them
won't buy it unless the answer is yes
it's hard to imagine that kids are going
to read my critical thinking book and
then say I wanna I wanna do a gender
transition I don't think that that's the
way it works no
Bryce says thanks for being my number
one podcast of 2022 on Spotify thank you
Bryce for listening to the show I
appreciate that okay let's continue
let's keep on keeping on here
um all right
uh oh they're back to the m m freakout
woke Eminems they're Furious about on
Fox News take a listen to this
well I know you were eating M M's before
the commercial break let's talk women M
M's
the company has just launched an
all-female pack to celebrate female
empowerment it features the company's
three female mascots green brown and the
newly introduced purple they don't even
have names why are we upside down
portrayed as women on that package
oh no
that's a great question Harris I don't
know I mean riveting apparently
apparently there's new lesbian
characters
um it's a female empowerment I just
didn't know that when I was eating like
an orange right now is this orange a man
or a woman well I I don't I don't know
is this blue is it non-binary is it
Democrat anybody know if this is comedy
or this is news honestly I can't tell
does can anybody weigh in substantively
is this supposed to be funny
or is this supposed to be news
people saying it sounds like satire it
sounds like it's it's supposed to be
funny but it's not Democratic I don't
know it's blue I don't know is it green
and maybe
all right anyway
you get the picture
in this fox clip
um Greg Gutfeld suggests maybe Biden has
Obama's real birth certificate Obama
my view I would sug I would always think
that the person who ever packed that
stuff in there probably just packs stuff
in there do you ever have a mover they
come to your house and then you're
unpacking and they packed singularly a
disposable spoon from from takeout and
it's all packed in newspaper drugs what
are you doing so who knows you know most
people
Greg Gutfeld may not know this most
people don't have the movers do the
packing because they can't afford it and
that's an interesting that it's quite
expensive actually you know the cheapest
thing is you do it all yourself the next
cheapest thing is you rent the truck and
you hire movers to load it the next
cheapest thing is you do all the packing
but the movers come and put everything
in the truck and drive the truck the
most expensive one is the movers do
everything and that's the only way that
the movers are going to end up packing a
spoon you didn't want but I don't think
Greg Gutfeld would know that but it's
not super relatable could be some idiot
who did that but but the thing is I
would not be doing my job if I didn't
raise the important questions that need
to be that need to be raised about what
actually happened yeah do we know that
there aren't nuclear secrets in there
perhaps he exchanged nuclear secrets to
China for the 10 percent huh that's
where that's a question is this comedy
again I can't tell if this is supposed
to be funny
I know Gutfeld sort of is a comedian I
don't even know what that really means
at this point
is this supposed to be funny I have no
idea question worth raising what if he
has Barack Obama's real birth
certificate oh no and that's
him the VP job
I don't know
I don't know
I I genuinely couldn't tell you whether
that is supposed to be real
and it's
stupid or it's supposed to be funny but
it's not it's a bad attempt at comedy is
what it sounds like yeah that that's
that's very much what it may be okay
here is Candace Owens talking about why
she likes to hunt
this should be interesting shoot it
directly in its Hearts so that the
animal does not suffer and that the
animal Falls and if you do injure it you
are required to track that animal until
the end until you find it because they
do not allow animals to suffer and I
took a breath and I fired and I shot the
animal directly in the heart
and then we ran up and it turns out that
it was going into some record book
because she had horns it was a queen
turned out that she was a queen a queen
spots another queen in the distance
and it's interesting because you see me
smiling in that photo and I always
remember thinking of these photos of how
could you you know how could you smile
next to an animal that's dead
I just want to make this clear this
moment
it wasn't about gloating that you had
killed an animal it was so beautiful it
gave me such a tremendous respect for
life and for death
and I was smiling because I had realized
that
I had reached another level in my own
development that
this person who doesn't want to exist to
believe that food comes out of a grocery
store that this person could now go out
and could hunt their own food
and that I was going to feed all of
these African children who are ecstatic
when the hunters come because they know
that they're going to get a bunch of
meat and that I was successful and I was
going to be able to bring them back with
me this this is seriously psychotic
seriously psychotic
and so
as I said before I don't want to be one
of those conservative cowards who
doesn't post these sorts of things
because oh they think people won't
understand I'm I'm proud I'm
tremendously proud of this moment and I
know that in the future all of my
children all of my Offspring will learn
to hunt and they will learn to shoot and
they will learn to live off of the land
and I realized that that has been my New
Year's resolution I think probably for
the last three or four years
is to truly become native to know where
I live to know how I can survive where I
live there is not only a psychotic
overtone to this
there's also a weaponized delusion of
grandeur here I don't know if you all
are picking up on that it's there's
multiple layers on which this is
operating
and
this you know we get we get vibes of
delusions of grandeur from Trump right
all the time
he's the best this he's the best that
whatever this is this is like extra
completely extra because when things get
bad and they do it's a cycle it is a
cycle we live in times of prosperity but
we've seen grocery stores this we've
seen the shelves cleared
and when times get bad
you kill a rhino and you eat it that's
exactly right dangerous dangerous
dangerous woman
um and again you know part of it is like
the people that fall for being like this
is you know this is who I listen to
this is the type of person I listen to
and and uh you know she it's funny
because she's also talking about
a paradigm of what she considers to be
Solutions
that are solutions
to the extent that they are solutions
they're to their solutions to problems
that her political movement caused right
that's it's sort of like here's how I'm
gonna put out the fire I started
um
it's
it's really crazy really really crazy I
want to remind everybody we are moments
away from the town hall at the top of
the hour we'll do the David packman show
Town Hall uh we will be doing it via
Discord you can join at davidpackman.com
Discord I want to remind you if you want
Priority Access during the town hall you
have to get verified as a website member
still time to sign up at joinpakman.com
website members during the town hall get
Priority Access you go to joinpakman.com
you can do monthly you can do yearly
either way is fine you hit the sign up
button as you can see above my head the
coupon code is please no more Trump and
when you type in that code
you see that you get an incredible
discount once you have a membership and
the membership can be a previous
membership or you get it today in the
Discord you go to contact mod team and
click the contact button and then simply
send proof of your membership you can
just take a screenshot of yourself
logged in on the website you will then
be tagged as a member and you will get
Priority Access during the town hall
which is about to start quite tonight is
the town hall first town hall of 2023
it's an amazing amazing thing I will
also suggest that if you're here re-up
your Twitch Prime subscription richbird
and Sling Blade and mushroom wand all
just did putting us at
27.27 and if we get to a hundred today
we will schedule a members only Town
Hall tonight's town hall is for
everybody
we get to 100 we'll do
um a members only Town Hall really
really soon also I have a very very
important announcement to make
for a long time now I've been
considering
how I can best contribute to the world
and these aren't easy decisions to make
they're decisions you know you have to
really think critically about and really
be sure that you're doing something that
you actually want to do
um and today I am it's weird to say it
it's weird to say it actually but I am
ready to announce that I am going to be
entering uh the running
to be the host of a YouTube channel with
two million subscribers I am ready to
throw my hat in the ring and say
I believe that as a host of a Channel
with 2 million subscribers I could be
really good and I could do good things
for people
so I want you to help me achieve that
you thought I was gonna run for
something give me a break guys I see
people getting all triggered
um I can't stand it last thing I want to
do is end up being George Santos you
know what I mean give me a break
uh no but in all seriousness we do want
to get to that 2 million number uh it
would be absolutely huge huge huge for
us so please hit that subscribe button
if you are watching on YouTube really
important we found out that in December
um uh something like 3.3 million
non-subscribers watched our content just
hit that subscribe button really easy
really quick I very much appreciate it I
need 11 000 votes give me a break please
uh okay I think I have time to squeeze
in a couple more things before the town
hall
um NH Barracks as David sir I had to
spend hundreds on a flight hundreds on a
rifle ammo training hunting guides Etc
to feed my family affordably exactly
that's exactly what Candace Owens is
saying yeah all right let's look at a
couple other things uh Matt schlapp who
runs CPAC
um and I as far as I knew was was you
know
heterosexual
um I guess he groped the genitals of a
male staffer and now the text messages
have gone public and it's pretty Bonkers
after Tech schlapped to inform him he's
not going to drive him he says I did
want to say I was uncomfortable with
what happened last night the campaign
does have a driver who's available to
get you to Macon and back to the airport
according to phone records we've
reviewed schlapp tries to call him a
couple of times then a few hours later
he sends the following text message if
you could see it in your heart to call
me at the end of the day I would
appreciate it if not I wish you luck on
the campaign and hope you keep up the
good work we also obtained a brand new
text message exchange that's being made
public for the first time this is the
staffer texted a friend who's in
politics really sort of telling him what
happened allegedly but also asking for
advice about how to tell the campaign so
the staffer tells this political friend
quote he's pissed I didn't follow him to
his hotel room then later the friend
responds I'm so sorry man what an effing
creep and then a little later the
staffer texts I just don't know how to
say it to my superiors that their
surrogate
fondled my junk oh my God consent
hmm
crazy stuff huh really really wacky
stuff oh we already looked at that
separately uh oh actually so so the
schlap thing it's all alleged you know
we're gonna keep an eye on it
um another moment from a different
Candace Owens video she says that if
someone tried to vaccinate her kid she
would she could she would potentially
kill them I just wanted to be very
honest about the fact that I went on a
hunt in Africa and it was something that
I felt very encouraged by has she
mentioned she went hunting guys
definitely something that I felt made me
more connected to the land and made me
more capable of surviving in the
wilderness if we happened upon tough
times and some people were really angry
as we were really offended by it I mean
one person by the way I remember reading
the comments said like this means if you
would do this to an animal that you
would do this to a human that you would
you have the capacity to kill a human
and I was very insulted by that because
I feel like
obviously canis Owens has the capacity
to kill a human I mean like though have
you seen have you like if somebody did
anything to my child anything you break
into my house you do anything I think is
going to harm my child there's never
been a question in my mind about whether
or not I have the capacity to kill a
human right if out she came up my kid
with a vaccine I'm not going to finish
that sentence because I have no big
Pharma has big guns and so I don't care
about she would kill fauci if fauci came
at her kid with a vaccine vile vile vile
woman truly I mean absolutely horrifying
completely and totally horrifying person
um cheers
these are the people that they
they have followers they have followers
that's the scariest thing I want to say
thanks to Johnny manogue as well as
Brian Shorey Mario Felice
and John Gillen for signing up on our
website joinpakman.com very much
appreciate that folks let's start the
town hall welcome welcome welcome let's
reset it is January uh what is the date
January 11th it is 6 p.m eastern time
and as promised it is time for the first
viewer Town Hall of
2023. this is going to be taking place
if you want to talk to me it is on
Discord please go to davidpackman.com
Discord get into the Discord and join
the waiting Lobby if you want to talk to
me please raise your hand or request to
speak I don't know exactly what
terminology it says we are going to be
talking to everyone who well I mean that
and not literally everyone but
people regardless of their membership
status on the website if you do sign up
at joinpakman.com and verify your
membership on Discord you are going to
get Priority Access Priority Access very
very important stuff uh and
what else uh please get right to your
questions you know all the normal stuff
just be aware of the fact that there's
other people that want to talk and then
just don't use speakerphone stuff like
that thanks to 503 Phoenix by the way
for the twitch Prime subscription I do
very much appreciate that
um should we just jump right in I mean
it is it's Town Hall day I feel like we
should we should just get going let's
start today let's start just as a
beginning okay and folks I don't know
how many times I have to say it do not
direct message me on Discord trying to
get on I will immediately block you I
can't deal with that crap okay do not
direct message me or call me on Discord
I will just block you
go to the waiting Lobby
and use the request to speak thing let's
start today with a website member we
will go to Elias from Texas
Elias please get right to your question
my friend
hey David
um is the US government and U.S
corporations are responsible for
destabilizing and preventing prosperity
in Latin American countries why do
conservatives
um are like this isn't our problem if
it's like a lot of those problems are
U.S made in my opinion
let me see if I understand the question
you're saying conservatives say Latin
American problems aren't their problem
but you're arguing like that it is their
problem
oh I'm saying that they failed to
acknowledge that a lot of these problems
are American made so like the like the
United Fruit Company and like all the
um
interventionist policies that um America
has done against Latin America like a
lot of those people are are fleeing like
broken governments but like they're
broken because a lot of of the activity
that America has done
um what what do you think about that yes
it's not surprising to me that right
Wingers refuse to acknowledge any time
that the U.S has had a negative role
anywhere in the world I think it's
important when we look at such complex
issues as Latin America you know an
entire region not to only blame the
United States but yeah there's no doubt
whatsoever that uh it's because yeah
yeah it's just
like Trump
like all these problems are
are um
many of them are like American
or their the origin can be traced back
to America in my opinion so all right
well Elias I appreciate you weighing in
on the issue and it is never a shock
when Republicans shirk responsibility
that we are accustomed to
um
there is Elias from Texas let's now go
to a non-member let's go to Matt from
Minnesota Matt from Minnesota welcome to
the first David packman show Town Hall
of 2023 if you're just joining us go to
davidpackman.com Discord to participate
members will get priority and you can of
course sign up at joinpakman.com very
very important place to sign up
um okay let's uh continue go ahead Matt
from Minnesota
hey David can you hear me I can hear you
fine sir
great uh so I'm actually a member but I
just need to link my Discord account oh
God okay well good thing I called on you
then
uh how do you determine the price for
your membership because you have sort of
a sliding scale and you provide it for
free for some people uh you know some
good sales uh how do you determine like
a one you know day to day like what to
offer for your price you determine the
price that's the incredible thing Matt I
don't determine it you determine it
whatever you want to pay as you can see
here is available although maybe I
misunderstand your your question you're
saying how did we choose these numbers
yeah yeah like so you have like a a full
price for example yes and you also have
occasional discounts oh absolutely
determine the full price versus how do
you determine how much to Discount I use
a divining Rod to figure out the
discounts quite frankly there's really
no science to it
okay yeah it's just kind of whatever I
feel like that day
uh all right Matt from Minnesota thank
you very much I appreciate the call
let's now go to Smitty from Los Angeles
a website member go ahead sir
hi David I want to start off by saying
that I uh really just appreciate this
podcast and I'm so glad I joined as a
member
um and I know that it must be incredibly
hard work each day to bring us these
shows and this information I know it
takes a lot of effort so I'm just really
enjoying it and uh wanted to just say
thank you for that wow I very much
appreciate the kind words thank you
yeah you're very welcome
um yeah I'm just really really enjoying
how you uh tackle you know responding to
the news that's going on and how you are
able to really parse it out I think you
just did a really good job
which is what we need to be doing
because we just really have to parse out
things
um
so anyway my question is
what do you
what do you think about people like Ben
Shapiro
um obviously he's a very intelligent
person and a lot of other
podcasters or political commentators
but do they not really understand the
true danger we're in are they just
willing to sacrifice it for the money I
mean obviously he he's very
very
oh boy Smitty you there buddy
uh we lost Smitty oh boy oh we lost them
uh listen you're sort of getting at a
very deep issue which is you're really
asking do people like Ben Shapiro
believe the things they say or do they
behind the scenes have a completely
different world view and I don't know
the answer to that I believe Shapiro is
honest in his views but you know it's
it's it's quite a quite a deep question
I will say
uh let's speak to
um one more website member and then
we'll go to a non-member and then it's
all it's all going to be great why don't
we go to Melody from Missouri Melody
from Missouri welcome to the program and
thanks for being a member on the website
hey David can you hear me yes I can
all right fantastic I was in on the last
call and you called on me and it was not
my phone glitched so I'm glad I'm able
to get on today I'm glad to all right so
my question is have you been following
uh the recent attacks on the LGBT
community uh specifically about drag
queens and drag shows yeah I mean my
understanding is that all of a sudden
there's all these concerns about drag
queen Story Hour and drag queens are
dangerous to children and all of a
sudden everybody's all worked up about
what they believe would be the
irreparable Damage Done to children from
being around drag queens right I mean is
that more or less what's going on
basically and they're calling drag
queens groomers and all this they
completely ignored drag Kings which I
perform as one which is why this is kind
of personal to me okay um but but
apparently uh women who dress like men
are not a threat but there's things like
you know the Missouri where I live
they're trying to pass legislation to
basically make drag shows the same as
strip clubs which would put a lot of
businesses under
um that sounds completely insane to me
I'm not gonna lie I mean again I'm not
you know there's so many different
issues absolutely and I'm only following
I'm only following some of them but but
that seems completely bonkers
it really is and honestly I
I just wanted to kind of bring awareness
to it and see like if you had
suggestions on what we might be able to
to do about this other than just like
writing to our politicians which no I
mean listen I just I wish I knew more
about the issue I have to say I've been
following the anti the overtly
anti-trans stuff more than the drag
queen stuff but my hope is eventually
they'll just move on but the problem is
when they move on they'll move on to
harassing someone else so it's like is
that better I don't know
yeah absolutely so yeah it's it's a
whole lot wrapped up in one it's a lot
of anti-trans a lot of anti-gay and
honestly misogyny says they're ignoring
the Kings which is fine with me but um
yeah so I just want to bring that up and
uh thank you for taking my call So when
you say you're a drag King this means
that you you sometimes dress like a man
is that basically what it means yes I
perform as as a male impersonator
basically
uh in the same way that Queens Do It
shows I it's a lot of people don't
realize that Kings have existed for as
long as queens and male impersonators as
long as female impersonators and we
perform just as much we do just as much
work and um you know I I've been like Mr
International gay Rodeo things like that
uh for uh for some time I've been
performing about seven years and it's so
what's the nature of the performance is
it singing is it dancing
a lot of the of the above it's again
similar to drag queens unless they're
like like there's a uh lip syncing is a
big part some of some of us sing some of
a lot of us dance I do a lot of a lot of
dancing a lot of country dancing
especially but wow do some comedy
you have to do some comedy numbers let's
sing to Weird Al people love it
but yeah if you ever have a chance to go
to a drag show that that has Kings in it
I encourage you to do so if you're ever
in Kansas City I'll invite you to one of
mine all right well I now have
invitations to NASCAR and dragon so I
have a lot of things I've got to get
done Melody yes absolutely all right
well thank you so much for the call
thank you all right Melody a very very
powerful website member let's go next to
Colleen not a website member as far as I
know everyone is welcome in this town
hall Colleen who is new to Discord which
is always potentially fraught uh I am
inviting Colleen to speak
and I hope that Colleen will soon be
joining us here
Colleen are you there
um
looks like we have a problem there with
Colleen's Discord elements I guess we
would call them and Colleen is gone well
let's try Sue in Albuquerque instead Sue
in Albuquerque not a member welcome to
the program sue if you unmute yourself
we'll be able to hear you and then off
we will go
can you hear me yes I can sue welcome
I am honored with tears in my eyes and
and you're you're a big tough person and
you're still crying over it I I am so
big and tough yeah and
I'd like to thank first the people in
your audience that call into your show I
just I I'm gladdened my heart is
gladdened by them they're such good
people but I wanted to ask you a
question David please
well um
expanding on what the other person a
little while back said about how great
your show is and how much we enjoy it
yeah and how much work it is probably
yes
um I wish there was a way you could do a
Spanish version because you know the
right has all their right wing things in
Spanish I know that just occurred to me
well Sue would it be okay if I made an
announcement during your phone call
oh it would be so so great you might
really end up crying after this
announcement okay
unfortunately I don't have time to do a
whole other recording in Spanish of the
show but but
we have entered we are in the process of
entering into an agreement with a
dubbing company that is going to dub our
content into Spanish it is going to live
on its own channel if people want to
fact check me it already exists if you
go to youtube.com I believe it's
David packman
espanol not espanol because you can't do
that thing in URLs anyway it's there
already okay there's no subscribers you
could be the first subscriber we've got
like a banner up
we are doing it we are doing it and
we're going to take the most important
stories of the day they will be dubbed
into Spanish and we because I agree with
you it is such an important thing so
much right-wing disinformation is
targeting American Spanish speakers
yes yes
okay
well so you broke some news Sue
thank you David my pleasure great to
hear from you
bye-bye I think Sue was so overcome with
emotion
about uh the announcement let me see if
I can actually find it uh let's see here
I'm telling you that it exists oh I
guess now with handles
yeah here it is look I found it
uh
uh yeah look at this folks I was not
lying when I told you four subscribers
look at that it's five subscribers this
is gonna be a great thing this is gonna
be a great thing and um I think it's
super super important super super
important okay uh let's continue with
the town hall we are going to go next to
let's go to Alex from Florida Alex from
Florida not a website member but
everyone is welcome and it's a pleasure
to welcome you on to the program
hey David can you hear me yes I can
thanks for having me I just had a quick
question do you think that oh boy
similar
can you hear me yeah
um we're getting a lot of blings and
dings I don't know whether we could do
something about that but let's go ahead
and see if we can get the question out
sure uh do you think that there's going
to be more January 6 type events like
the ones that happened in Brazil
throughout
other countries in the coming years
sadly I do sadly I do unless and here's
the big caveat
if the Insiders of these events
particularly the Trump riots
uh are really held to account
um I think that we are going to see more
attempts at similar events and it it
pains me to say that
and what kind of solution do you think
we could find to kind of stop this from
happening well it needs to be abundantly
clear
to those who would be willing to incite
such violence that they will be punished
right if Trump and his cronies were
punished not just the patsies the
rioters right but the actual people
doing the inciting if they were punished
I think others around the world would
look at it very differently
okay that's what I was thinking as well
yeah yeah
what part of Florida are you in
I'm in Pompano Beach oh okay so that's
if I recall correctly that's like
between Miami and uh it's like north of
Fort Lauderdale right
yes yeah yeah I'm going to be in that
area I actually when I'm down there for
the Patrick Bet David show I'm going to
a very powerful uh a power brunch with
some people and we're going to be
somewhere in the you know Deerfield
Beach Pompano Beach area any any brunch
spots you would recommend like out nice
outdoor seating maybe on the water
I don't do brunch so that's really
something that could help is that a
moral principle you're just opposed to
brunch or there's something about eggs
you don't like
uh that's a moral principle really yeah
I don't like getting up too early to uh
to do brunch oh oh oh oh but you know
brunch could be 12 30. yes is that I'm
not a big fan of like breakfast food
okay okay like what's your typical
breakfast
coffee and some fruit fruit's great I
love fruit all right all right my friend
well listen consider eggs benedict
someday you know
I've had them you've had it all right
even smoked salmon Benedict you're still
not into it nope nope okay well Alex
you're still you're still welcome on the
show regardless
well thank you very much all right there
is Alex from Florida we are in the
middle of the first David Pacman show
Town Hall of the year I want to say
thanks to McKinley and Flash Gordon for
the twitch Prime subscriptions I also
want to say thank you to Julia Min you
for signing up at joinpakman.com we are
getting things going again and if we get
to 100 website members and twitch
subscribers we will do a member only
Town Hall very very soon if you'd like
to talk to me right now go to
davidpackman.com Discord it's the place
to be and join the waiting Lobby where
you can also verify your website
membership let's as we often do check in
with Tamisha from New York City Tamisha
welcome how are things it's been a while
Tamisha welcome you're muted you've got
to unmute yourself
oh boy
we're not going to miss Tamisha are we
Tamisha you're on but it seems like you
have maybe the wrong audio device
selected
um
all right Tamisha I'm going to move you
back into the audience if you get that
audio thing fixed we will uh we'll give
it another shot okay I always always
great to check in with Tamisha let's go
next to
Colin from Portland now is it Portland
Maine or is it Portland Oregon Colin and
calling David you hey how are you oh
good you can hear me I can hear you fine
awesome uh it's Portland Oregon
beautiful
yeah so I'm a long time listener first
thing caller appreciate that um and I've
got a lot of questions but I've got one
that I wanted to ask you I wanted to ask
you about Ron DeSantis sure is that okay
yeah that's fine
um cool
um I'm in that group that thinks he
could be more dangerous than Trump okay
you know just based on some of the
um things I've you know some of the
research I've done on him but I'm
curious to I have a question for you
with why do you think he's so reluctant
to talking about his military history I
didn't know that he was what do you what
in what sense is he is he reluctant this
is the first time hearing that well I've
seen some some interviews with him in
the past where he's just kind of avoided
or dodged the questions about his
military history and
um yeah and I I actually listened to
another podcast with a um it was with a
it was kind of like a military veteran
left Progressive podcast and they were
talking to people they're actually
talking to somebody who was at
um Guantanamo Bay and he was talking he
was talking about how
he remembers Ron DeSantis in his
involvement at gitmo and how he was you
know basically a despicable person
yeah and it goes into some really some
some detail about things that he
supposedly did that was very uh hard to
hear
and um yeah no it was just weird and
then after that I guess he did a tour in
Fallujah which was kind of like special
ops and they didn't really talk much
about it so I was just curious because I
think there's a lot that is kind of
still yet to be known I it sounds like
it I I have to tell you I I am not an
expert in Ron DeSantis although I agree
with you that I think he has the
potential to be more dangerous than
Trump but I'll have to look into the
military service thing I just don't know
enough about it uh people are suggesting
maybe he had a military he had a
disciplinary record or whatever I don't
know let's investigate let's figure it
out yeah because it sounds he was
basically a Jag officer which was
basically a military lawyer right and he
was there to kind of oversee the the um
day-to-day kind of well torture
basically right but yeah it's
interesting so
um yeah that's my question and um I just
emailed you about the studio overlay
help actually too because I'm a graphic
designer oh good and and you have
experience doing overlays
yes that's what I do so that's good all
right we'll get it we'll be in touch
then for sure
sounds great thanks dude all right Colin
from Portland continues moving us along
very very strongly here on the
um on the first town hall of the Year
let's go next to
you know I I'm gonna go to Jamie from
Boise but Boise is misspelled and
usually people spell the place that
they're in so it's a little bit of a
risk but we're gonna see we're gonna go
to Jamie from Boise and see what the
deal is
if Jamie is able to
connect and get their
thing up and running
uh no and they're gone all right well
let's try Tamisha from New York City one
more time and see if Tamisha has
resolved her technical issues that were
plaguing her last attempt to Misha we
are welcoming you in
you have to accept the invitation and
then you'll be able to talk to me
but it seems as though hey Tamisha
can you hear me I can hear you yes
welcome
hi
how's it going
it's good I'm calling today to talk
about um I wanted to ask you a question
about um do you think that the the right
strong man's most of the issues that the
left talks about give me some examples
like you know how it went on the right
says that um that
um we're trying to to change biology as
far as like women and men all right yeah
I would say that's a bit of an
exaggeration to Misha I think I don't
think that that's an accurate
representation of what the left wants
when they say hey maybe we should sort
of like treat trans people like people
because they're people yeah I don't
think change biology is what the left is
trying to do
exactly and and
a that we're trying to uh that that I
feel like it's more of
change not changing but having different
identities then it's not really the
biology that's trying to change yes we
know that women are born certain ways
and men are born certain ways but they
may not identify with the way they were
born yeah and I think it's not the only
example you know the on the abortion
issue you often hear oh the left wants
to kill babies when they're actually two
and they're toddlers And it's like no
nobody wants that that's actually I've
never heard that ever from anybody
um I think I think that applies to a lot
of different issues to be totally honest
and also um another example is when um I
was talking to my sister's husband and
he was saying that he felt like men
women are trying to take over men and
get more and I felt like no they're just
trying to be that's one of those things
your sister's husband is a right winger
right if I recall correctly
he's um well he's he's weird because
they live in Atlanta Georgia yeah and he
vote he so he confessed that he voted
for Trump but he also did not vote for
he wrote it for Stacy Abrams and he did
not vote for Walker in the last election
interesting well listen that's one of
the it's like what did they even mean by
some of this stuff it it's really hard
to have conversations when people make
such like General overarching comments
like that and you know it's your call
whether you you think it's worth
engaging with it
I know I try to but it's fruitful some
fruitless sometimes I like and toasted
gabbard post about trans issues a lot
yeah she's getting sucked into it she's
getting sucked into it biology she's
gone Hook Line and Sinker with some of
those cultural issues that have that are
popular with many on the right right now
she's basically a right winger at this
point I mean who's who you know hard to
deny it you know seems like and and a
lot of the people
um who respond to her full like Hook
Line and Sinker into the things she's
saying yeah without a doubt without a
doubt Tamisha always great to hear from
you the kids are okay
everybody's great thank you and your
baby's so cute any advice on
um uh any advice on food stuff like you
know if she starts rejecting certain
foods what what was your strategy do you
just move on and try that food again a
different day
yes I oh you you you don't force ever
forth I grew up being forced to eat
right so I'm I'm the extreme I don't
force my kids to eating anything yep but
I just try to expose them to different
things and you know taste buds change
over time so maybe you try something
again yeah she hasn't really rejected
anything yet she's had like 25 different
foods I can tell you there are certain
foods that she likes so much that we we
have to limit access to them because
it's so triggering to her it winds her
up and she goes crazy for certain foods
so far it's common for children to
fixate on certain foods and they'll
sometimes they'll only want to eat that
food right and you know she's only seven
months so so a lot of this she can't
really verbalize but we gave her we're
doing this this like baby LED weaning
thing where you skip the mushes and you
go you go straight to like real foods
you know I don't know if you've heard of
that
yes and so we gave her a mango pit and
it was like this thing was Liquid Gold
or fruit gold it's just obsessed with
the mango pit and sucking on the mango
pit gave her a chicken drumstick safely
you remove the pin bone you remove the
fat and the cartilage went Bonkers for
it and then a piece of steak just you
would have thought that this was uh that
her life depended on on sucking on this
piece of steak the and I know people are
joking about the mat I'm dead serious
about the mango I think those three are
her favorite food so far I think that's
adorable yeah no it's quite a scene but
uh it's uh it's it's a real party as you
know
enjoy all right Tamisha great to hear
from you thanks you too take care bye
um okay let's can folks let's continue
why why would we stop now I want to
speak next if possible if possible and
it it really may not be to Theodore from
one of my favorite cities in the world
Paris France assuming Theodore are you
in in Paris France that's the Paris
you're calling from
indeed I am it's the real Paris which
neighborhood are you in generally
uh generally
um I'm in the 12th District so that
would be near 12th I don't remember
where that is
it's near the one of the main train
stations
oh yeah so that's north of the river
right
yeah that's exactly it yeah I once
picked up a rental car there and uh it
was very hectic driving out I have to
say
yeah I bet it is it still is to be
honest well what's on your mind today
that's for messages yeah well um
I don't know how much you know about
French French politics like I don't
figure you know so much maybe only a
little bit but
what usually happens in France is that
we tend to see American Trends come to
us four five or six years after they
happen in your country and I'm really
starting to see that now with the right
wing uh in France really going full-on
culture War full-on uh brandishing
wokism as kind of the great Menace to
Society now which is not something
the the far right used to do and so what
I'm wondering is if you have any good
advice good tips for us to really start
countering this before it becomes a
whole thing like it is in America right
now you know I really don't and the
reason why I don't is we haven't figured
out how to successfully counter it here
in the United States I think a lot of it
is having one-on-one conversations where
you explain that these wacky wild
examples of so-called wokism really
aren't representative of what the vast
majority of the left actually is but a
lot of these right Wingers don't want to
hear that they they've grasped on to
this idea of going after wokism and they
don't care if what they describe by
wokism is actually extraordinarily rare
I think vote for candidates that won't
play to that but obviously if there's
enough people to vote for the candidates
that will your vote alone isn't going to
going to save you guys but I wish I had
better advice we've we've sort of failed
in the United States on that
well let's not be true defeatist I think
maybe we can you can still beat it and
maybe we can still beat it too but yeah
I I guess what I really fear is to see
the the far right lean on this menace to
to change the topic of conversation when
what we should really be talking about
is what to do about climate change right
social inequalities I don't want to get
hang up on workism it's not even a real
problem you know right and you know
Theodore the thing about it is
there's a reason why right-wing
movements in many parts of the world are
going in this direction and abandoning
policy it's because the more we learn
about the real world the more we realize
that their policy ideas don't work right
the more we learn about the reality of
climate change the more that their
climate science denial doesn't make any
sense the more that we learn about how
trickle-down economics doesn't actually
help an economy the less sense their
Economic Policy makes so what do they
have left when you when you demonstrate
that all of their policy doesn't work
wokism trans issues you know M M's being
sexualized or whatever
I can't believe that is a real actual
issue it's a real thing here I know it's
crazy yeah
I'm curious where is it raining there or
what's going on in the background
um oh sorry is there a background noise
yeah I'm curious what it I'm not
complaining I'm just curious what it is
um it's not rain I think it's probably
my my speaker oh okay right now you've
got a speaker making noise in the room
um I don't know how to say my mic oh
your microphone your mic oh I see okay
well listen I am very much looking
forward to getting back to Paris and I
hope to be back very very soon
well I hope you'll enjoy it when you'll
go there again all right Theodore from
Paris great to hear from you I have to
say I I think the town hall was going
pretty well I want to say thanks to
cabamus and J.P the Beast for their
twitch Prime subscriptions this is a
great day to sign up on my website as
well Tom Scala just became a website
member number 42 if we get to 100 I will
schedule a members only town hall for a
forthcoming day which I think is a
really really great thing to do
uh why don't we go next where are we
going next let's go to Shannon from Iowa
interesting part of the country Shannon
welcome to the program I would love to
hear what's on your mind today
um
Shannon hello hi
hi can you hear me yes I can okay so I
have a few things and I'm so excited um
to be on
um first comment about the drag queen
issue yeah there's really no difference
between taking your kids out on
Halloween and a drag queen show okay you
know in the reality of it I in my idea
do you have kids
I have yes I have triplets that are
grown and then I have a singlet that's
eight years younger you have four kids
including triplets yes is that even
legal
well it's funny story because I was 18
when I had them naturally wow yeah hold
on a second
there was no
there was no intervention that makes
multiples more likely just by chance no
you you had triplets at age 18.
absolutely naturally wow two boys and a
girl and and how does that work
um well you know what you just kind of
figure it out as you go yeah you know I
remember having two bottles under each
arm and one between my feet to feed them
at the same time and you get really
creative with rolling blankets and you
know
um one of the best days of my life was
when they could each hold their own
bottle right freed me up which was what
at like age eight or something like that
well a little bit younger but you know
they're awesome kids and uh they're all
super super smart and what moved me
today was when you were talking about
your book for The Young and the the way
of thinking and I don't know if it's
because I was young but I I raised my
kids with having an open conversation
house and right and challenging them to
think and I don't know if that's why
they were always always I mean top-notch
genius smart and it's yeah I don't know
where it comes from but I do think that
having that kind of openness to thought
of
thought of thinking right and they're
all super successful and funny when you
were talking about breakfast because my
daughter owns the best brunch place in
Des Moines Iowa really and it's half a
mile from my house you would absolutely
love it her husband just won a chef of
the Year from the Iowa Restaurant
Association and it's yeah called little
brother it is the best breakfast in the
midwest so well I may just have to check
that out next time I find myself in Des
Moines that's sounding pretty good it's
really good yeah so yeah I just I really
want to give you Kudos I think you can
really help expand the minds of of our
young and uh we're gonna do it yeah for
people who are wondering what Shannon's
talking about we're putting the
finishing touches on a children's
Illustrated children's book about
critical thinking it's not a political
book it's just getting you know kids to
understand how do you ask questions how
do you figure out if something's true
really simple stuff to create the
foundation that I've been saying for a
decade they should have we're gonna do
it and I'll have more information about
it soon Shannon I'm so excited
congratulations thank you so much for
what you do thank you Shannon weather's
okay there
um yeah it's just 30 35 degrees not too
bad really not bad all right thank you
so much for the call I appreciate it
you're welcome thank you all right
Shannon from Iowa triplets at 18. that
is she really she should be writing the
book I don't know why I'm writing a book
she's she's the one who should be
writing the book uh all right let's go
to website member SD from Dallas Texas I
do want to say thanks to hippopotamus
Bosch
uh for the twitch Prime subscription I'm
guessing that that's a reference to
Hieronymus Bosch the uh the TV show
which is a pretty damn good show I have
to say also thanks to Ryan S chazier I
don't know if I pronounced that
correctly your new member number 44
today but SD welcome what's on your mind
yes I can it's it's not a great
connection that we have but I can hear
you technically
sorry hold on oh there you go that's
that's normal better
is this better yeah
all right let's see thanks for taking my
uh call uh it's been a while
um my question is mostly uh so of course
like regulation is absolutely needed but
sometimes like when there is too much it
can give like all regulation a bad name
so my question to you is are there any
forms of like deregulation that like you
currently are like really in favor of
that's a really good question you know
there probably are uh but I I can't
think offhand of any particular
particular regulation that I'm sort of
like uh pushing for are there any you
can think of that I should consider
um there are currently a few that I do
have in mind there's like some forms of
Occupational licensing that to me like
when somebody uh tell me about it I
thought okay yeah maybe that's a little
too much yeah and then uh there's other
like small things that I think of like
are that are non-binding regulations but
still overall give regulation a bad name
so
like for example like in the industry
that like I work in like almost
everything has a prop 65 label on it oh
yeah you know what that is yeah where it
says like it may cause cancer
yeah yeah yeah exactly and so and
especially like with a lot of like uh
Home Improvement goods and building
materials like everything has the label
on it right like almost everything so
that's something to me where like it
doesn't discourage anybody from buying
the product but it's still overall kind
of gives regulation a bad name I've even
heard people bring it up to me like in
conversation to uh tell me how bad
regulation is that's interesting yeah I
mean I think that it's that's relative
the things you're listing are minor
enough
that it sounds like we aren't
dramatically over regulated in this
country and in fact I would I would
argue that in many Industries we are
under regulated but I am very much on
board with what you're saying that I
don't favor regulation for the sake of
Regulation I want regulations that make
sense and are needed and are appropriate
for the circumstances not regulation
just for the sake of controlling
Industries or people
I think that's a really great way to put
it
but do you agree we're not really if
we're over regulated it's very very
narrowly it's for the most part we don't
have a country that is over regulated
uh for the most part I I agree yeah all
right that's fair
all right well thanks SD appreciate that
thank you
all right thank you SD from Dallas
couple super chats Philip says David
what are your thoughts about the Prince
Harry 60 Minutes interview I didn't see
it to be honest
um he said when he was in boarding
school William told him to act like they
didn't know each other yeah I didn't see
I really don't care about Royal stuff
industry says glad you're backstreaming
how we're baby and baby mama doing
everybody's doing well
um my uh seven month old daughter is
playing the drums now I posted a video
of that to my Instagram
a little bit of an exaggeration I think
to say she's playing the drums but no
everybody's good everybody's good let's
go next to Tiffany from Miami who is a
website member Tiffany welcome to the
program
hi there this is actually my second time
calling I thought I recognized Tiffany
from Miami yeah how are you
I'm doing well how are you I'm well
thank you
uh yeah just quick question this time
um so last time I called I called about
the possibility of a federal abortion
ban
um I agree with you now I don't really
think it would happen but my question is
uh do you think well uh the Republicans
will abandon abortion as a political
football now that they know it affects
them really negatively in elections I uh
don't think so I think that they will
tailor and craft their anti-abortion
message to be more narrow and specific
they'll probably back off of the no
exception stuff like I think they
recognize that no exceptions didn't work
particularly well for them yeah it looks
crazy which is insane yeah of course but
I don't think they're going to abandon
the message more broadly I think I just
think they'll narrow it and tailor it a
little bit because they still raise a
ton of money being against abortion from
Evangelical and religious groups so you
can't do away with it you just gotta
tailor it a little bit
yeah I think I think you're right on
that one and uh you know thanks for
taking my call your baby is super cute
by the way thank you and and by the way
I'm I'm sure I I am very much looking
forward to in a couple weeks getting
down to Miami and
um getting away from the cold and I'm
gonna be doing the Patrick Bet David
show down there the Anthony pompliano
show I'm gonna go to some Argentinian
restaurants and all sorts of great Miami
things assuming I don't get covered
again you know that's the big thing
well you just got it so I don't think
you'll get it a second time back to back
that's my hope that's my hope we're all
hoping we're all praying Tiffany yes
anyway have a good day all right thank
you uh Tiffany from Miami absolutely
fantastic to hear from her
let's go next to Juan
from Florida is what's going on I can't
click one
oh no my entire thing is glitching
I can't bring anyone on
uh
oh it looks like there's certain people
I can't bring on
is it because they don't have
it's weird oh no here we go
okay now we're good Juan from Florida
Welcome to the stream let me know what
is on your mind today
if you can join sir
Juan has been invited
but I don't know what is going on with
Juan
uh
all right oh here's Quan welcome
hey
uh you should recognize my voice it's
true is this troll man oh boy
what's up man what's going on
no I'm just I miss uh chiming in here uh
it's finally good to interact even
though all you've heard is my millions
of voicemails
yeah I uh you know the the voicemail
line has over 1200 unlistened to
voicemails we can't even come close to
keeping up with it so some may be uh
destined for you know the archives
unfortunately
yeah well I just wanted to say that uh
you know
I think your uh your show is good and uh
even though we don't agree on
several things I think you do a good job
thank you my mind is uh Full Of Weeds
usually but uh part of the reason I
leave your voicemails is to try to
I guess Express things that are going on
in my head as far as topics politics and
stuff like that right uh I don't really
you know plan these things out it's just
spontaneous and stuff but uh you know I
just basically chimed into you know to
apologize if I get overwhelming in
voicemails but
sometimes
I just don't understand so many things
man well that's okay apology accepted I
think I would say
yeah but anyway uh it's good that you're
doing what you do and uh it's good that
you're on live for again actually it's
great and we're gonna make it a regular
thing Juan okay
all right buddy uh again I know that I'm
that I
leave a lot of weird voicemails and
probably some of them annoying but
there's just so much stuff that I don't
understand and no problem and just so
you're so you know we haven't sent any
of them to law enforcement they have not
been concerned that way okay oh no
worries man no worries uh I'm sure that
my doctor could provide some reasoning
for my chaotic voicemails oh well we
don't want to get into my HIPAA though
so let's not go there all right man
anyway uh okay do a good job and uh I
wish you the best my friend thank you
all right there is Juan from Florida
let's go to Hannah from Georgia Hannah I
remember you calling in because your
your name has a very unusual spelling
and we were trying to figure out how
it's pronounced and it's just Hannah it
turns out right
uh yeah great well welcome back
oh sorry
um yeah thank you for having me uh
and I did have two questions if that's
okay no well let's evaluate the first
one and if it's good then we'll go with
a second one is that fair
yeah
um so I was gonna say like how uh the
right kind of runs on like what the left
potentially wants to do and they run on
like you know all trying to stop it
but if we if like if there were to
actually be accomplishments and like
regulations for like guns big Pharma
corporations stuff like that is that
just giving them ammo to where now they
can run on like we need to repeal this
or we need to you know enact our own
legislation to cover for what they just
did like instead of it being a what if
thing if we actually do accomplish
things
I think that if so what you're what
you're essentially saying is should the
left forego doing good things because it
gives the right ammunition to run on
repealing those things I think oh well
not not that they shouldn't do it or
that it's probably the right reaction to
it it absolutely would and uh that's
okay I mean it's it absolutely would be
the rights reaction but that doesn't
mean that the left shouldn't pursue
policies that make sense and are good
for people but yeah without a doubt that
would be the reaction yeah
um and did you want the second question
sure I think the first one was good
enough to get a second question
okay
um so my other question was like uh you
know if you thought there was a way to
break the two-party system without
having like a really great impact for
however many years it takes to kind of
sort it out on like the economy climate
quality of life immigration stuff like
that
um and like so is it better to like
break the two-party system have like
years of turmoil uh or just try to work
within the two-party system to try to
accomplish Progressive agendas you know
the great thing is you you got to do
both there's enough people and enough
activists that you can work inside and
outside of the democratic party and the
unfortunate reality is that for third
parties to really have a shot at
significant that significance I think is
the way I would say it I've listed the
things that have to change
um we need to go to public financing of
Elections we need to go to some version
of rank choice or transferable voting
there's all these different things that
have to be done
um and we have to work on that but if
you just do that then you accomplish
nothing in the meantime so you've got to
do you know it's so it's it's cliched
but they call it an inside outside
strategy and you've got to work inside
the Democratic party to make it as
Progressive as we can and we've got to
work outside to try to give third
parties uh closer to even footing
yeah for sure
all right well Hannah great to hear from
you again I appreciate the call
yeah thank you all right there goes
Hannah from Georgia let's go next to
Blake from Birmingham now is this
Birmingham UK or Birmingham Alabama
uh Alabama Alabama all right very good
uh what's on your mind today
yeah just more of an open-ended question
um I'm very interested in Cuba uh the
people the government and everything
yeah I was wondering if you thought
anything may happen with the U.S Cuban
relations
whether it's under a Biden
Administration or otherwise could it be
considered as an easy win or is it just
not really worth the effort at the time
not worth the effort at the time for
Biden so this is again I I would love to
see all sorts of normalization with Cuba
I am not a communist as many people know
I'm no fan of the castros or any of it
but I do think that there is a
significant double standard in U.S
relations with Cuba and I would be very
much in favor of doing something but
there's no way Biden's going to touch it
in the next two years particularly to
the extent that you need the house
involved which you would in some ways
and not in others now with a republican
house it's even more of a non-starter
um yeah I mean you're not going to see
anything done on Cuba I don't think in
the next two years
if if something were attempted to be
done do you think the best case would be
a humanitarian case above any others
uh you know honestly I mean so I think
that the humanitarian case is a great
case morally I think based on who our
elected officials are the most likely
case to succeed at making some progress
would be an economic case quite frankly
okay that's fair makes sense I
appreciate it David thank you all right
Blake from Birmingham great to hear from
you very very much appreciate it why
don't we go next to
uh where are we gonna go here because
there's a lot of people what about
Jackie in
is it Jackie in Jacksonville or is it
Jackson I can't quite see it Jackie
where where are you calling from
are you even there let's start with that
question Jackie
hmm Jackie has been invited
hello can you hear me yeah it is
Jacksonville isn't it
it is Jacksonville actually North
Carolina oh Jacksonville North Carolina
or well welcome to the program
yeah the other Jacksonville thank you
I'm a long time listener thank you um
our first time caller appreciate it
what's on your mind and I have um a lot
on my mind actually and um mainly a
concern and a question
um a little bit of my background I have
just made like a fresh Escape From what
I call the hill of East Tennessee okay
uh I'm a black transgender woman
and
um I am originally from Tennessee I'm an
original Tennessee and and you can
imagine the kind of
um dress and and turmoil tedium that
we've had to deal with as uh people of
color in the South but at the layer of
transgender yeah and then it compounds
right sounds horrible to be honest
it's absolutely horrific and um it's
disturbing and quite frankly uh very
concerning especially my concern
specifically has to do with
um the amount of anti-translates or
anti-trans uh legislation that has just
been put out freshly in the great year
of uh 2023 right before you know before
basically even you know Happy New Year
is finished being saved by the by the
society as a whole you know you have
members of the GOP introducing
legislation that is targeted at
diminishing our quality of life
and um it's very upsetting we have a lot
of people in this community that are
looking for equity and looking for
parity and
um tired of really asking for it but
instead thinking moving forward that we
should start demanding
um that is my concern if you will
my question as a transgender activist
and I'm an lgbtq plus uh Advocate yep
what can we
um do as a community as a transgender
Community he has a queer Community what
can we do
to better
um
how should I put it
to better
um demand our quality of respect our you
know our parity in this society that is
intentionally demeaning
um transgender people especially Trends
I think it's a great question I think
the issue with you know I can really
only comment on this generically in the
sense of what can anyone do to bring
their issue more to the Forefront and of
course it's starting to run for office
at every level meaning everything from
parent-teacher Association up through
the highest you know federal Offices and
everything in between
contacting media
uh a concerted effort to get media
spotlights on issues of importance and
things that are you know it's it's sort
of generic to any issue that you're
trying to put into the Forefront I think
the specific game plan on this issue
should really be led within the
community and so you know beyond that
generic idea I think it's for people who
are are part of the community to really
figure out the best way to go forward
rather than for me to kind of suggest I
I beyond the generic stuff I'm not sure
right and that's just it
um is that you know the I work for a
trans charity organization legitimate
501c3 yep and our plan is to bring our
allies to the Forefront and to empower
our allies you know there there's a lot
of um sister people out here who
um you know with the the colloquialism
of Silence being complicity right when
you have you know our allies the people
who actually support us and you know
want to give us the fair shake at having
our uh you know our uh parody and uh
pursuing happiness and entertaining it
you know when they're silent and not
speaking on our behalf you know
um uh uh how can we better draw them in
to empower them and well not even them
but you for instance you know what I'm
saying how can we get you out here being
a a voice for a transgender parity and
equality and all that stuff yeah I mean
this is a big issue in general when it
comes to allies and it goes beyond the
trans Community which is activating
allies but not so much that the Allies
start coming in and imposing what they
believe should happen over those who are
actually members of the group like this
is a big thing with the entire you know
um uh latinx thing which I don't use and
you know as a as a Hispanic American
when random you know white Americans say
whether it should or shouldn't be used
or whatever it starts to sort of be like
well how about my view from within the
community you know you know what I mean
so I think it's I think it's important
to find that balance
and shout out to the governor of
Arkansas who just banned Latin
yeah absolutely
has her First Act banding is a whole
other story you know that maybe is going
on yeah absolutely well listen Jackie I
appreciate the call you're raising some
really important issues and I I want you
to keep us posted on what else you get
involved in down there and whether
there's any progress absolutely surely
will and thank you so much I am a fan of
the show oh my gosh um just the
eloquence that you come with and the
honesty that you put or present to the
audience is
um above and beyond so congratulations I
appreciate it congratulations on that
beautiful little girl as well thank you
um
Jackie from Jacksonville great to hear
from you very very powerful messaging
and uh important stuff going on and what
great people doing great things all over
the place let's go next to Dylan from
Tijuana in Mexico Dylan are you the guy
from Tijuana who's called before
I am welcome back
thank you thank you
so yeah I'm just going through some
financials right now David and that's
what my question relates to is that uh
is that
I live a complicated uh lifestyle
because I'm dual National with us and
Mexico so tax tax wise I have to pay
both the IRS and Hacienda
what country do you work in
uh Mexico you work in Mexico but you're
a U.S citizen and so because of the the
rules you still have to file a tax
return in the U.S but isn't the tax you
pay to Mexico isn't that deducted from
what you owe the U.S
uh that is correct but still yeah yeah
that is correct okay fair but still it's
like us is one of one of only two
countries that taxes uh taxes their
expats you know right correct if I if I
had Australian or Canadian citizenship I
wouldn't have to worry about this but
right do you think do you think this is
fair why or why not ah do I think it's
fair you know that it's so fraught when
it comes to anything about taxes to say
is it fair and the problem with is it
fair
is is it fair to who right is it fair to
the taxpayer is it fair and just when it
comes to the community or the country or
whatever I mean listen in some
superficial sense if you're a Mexican
Citizen and your only income is in
Mexico does it really make sense to be
paying taxes to the United States
not really right I mean like that that's
my superficial just sort of like no it
doesn't really make sense when you think
about it that way I know that there are
people who can make a case for why it
does make sense
um but you know I I don't have a super
strong position but thinking about it
very superficially it doesn't make a
whole bunch of sense and the US does
make it really difficult even if you
move elsewhere get citizenship elsewhere
and work elsewhere I believe unless you
like renounce your U.S citizenship you
have to continue at least filing a tax
return and if you have tax liability you
got to pay the taxes
yeah yeah yeah exactly uh uh that's a
that's that's a big uh that's a big
Abyss we can fall into about U.S
citizenship renunciation but uh that's a
whole other story yeah now doesn't it
don't don't the U.S and Mexico have a
treaty people are telling me that
specifically prevents double taxation
it's true it comes down to that tax
credit that you alluded to okay uh the
existence of the tax credit is a product
of the treaty got it uh but but yeah
it's just like you know because I've
been loving the by the way loving the uh
David backman Financial Channel since I
have to deal with US dollars in Mexican
pesos all the time thank you I
appreciate that it's it's a lot to think
about it's like but yeah it's like you
know you know yeah because I I kind of
resent paying especially California
state tax like just because I have a
mailbox because I go over the Border
California is like oh you have a mailbox
and so you conduct business in
California tax
but you're not you're not you're not
paying California tax it's one of those
things where you're you're just what do
you pay in California just like on a
fraction of the business that you do in
California is that what it is yeah well
it's called a California non-resident so
it's like you know it's like so I have
to pay that and then declare to the IRS
and then declared Hacienda right down
here in Tijuana so it's like at I'm just
like it just creates such a such a mess
I'm like it is a mess it is and whatever
your view is on what the tax rates
should be I think we can all agree that
the totality of the system is a mess
even if you think the tax rates are high
lower just right
and my final thought is I don't enjoy
the services for which I'm paying taxes
to on the U.S side whereas in when I pay
Hacienda I do enjoy the services like
the health care and the roads and the
infrastructure that are set up by by
Mexican entities right because I live
here because that's where I live and so
it's like it's uh you know where one
lives it's kind of different if when I
when I had to just pay uh the president
for deep one and it's like fine that
though those uh
that that tax payment I just made uh I
enjoy those roads and and that those
services that uh that that pays for but
with the US it's just like throwing
money into a into an abyss hey as far as
Tijuana is concerned I know that there
are parts of Mexico further east on the
border that are known for dental and eye
care because people from the U.S cross
over and it's very good care very
reasonable rates is Tijuana as a border
City also known for that or less so
very much so actually Tijuana is named
one of the uh best medical tourism
destinations of the world huh
um so yeah what do you literally when
you cross the border if you cross the
border as a pedestrian you're you're
accosted by people uh for you you know
pharmaceutical uh you know medical
services and stuff like that there's
actually at the and when you return
there's actually a special medical Lane
for individuals who uh have had
procedures where the weight is going to
be shorter oh interesting hey I just I
came down to a Tijuana dentist you get a
special Lane that the dentist will give
you a special yeah I I know of someone
who went you know they they had a lot of
a long period of time during which they
couldn't afford and didn't have dental
insurance or couldn't afford the work
and they went down and they had first of
all a dentist did everything rather than
you know a hygienist and then a dentist
now you could say the hygienists are
used to doing the cleaning so they're
going to do a cleaning just fine if
they're accustomed to it but the point
is in some general sense you imagine the
dentist's time is normally more
expensive than the dental hygienist time
but they they had a dentist do a
cleaning
um some cavities
whitening and Invisalign and it was like
300 and the office was beautiful they
said it was just like the best treatment
and on and on and on you know I'm sure
you know about it
oh yeah yeah yeah the the the the the
dentists here are great and as well as
like uh cosmetic surgery and other such
things that U.S uh insurance policies
typically won't cover yeah because I've
definitely been I've definitely been
with you you've mentioned recently on
your show that
why isn't dental coverage part of you
know part of normal your your normal
stuff you know it should be it really
should know and and it's created a great
industry down here in Tijuana for for
for uh for dental care and
cosmetic like I said cosmetic stuff and
other things that uh and just other kind
of general like you know
um elective surgeries or something or
yeah I would be a little skeptical on
I'd be I'd be a little more hesitant on
um cosmetic surgery in a different
country because then you know you come
back if there's complications and the
follow-up when you've had it out of the
country yeah I've read that the Cosmetic
thing you've got to really research big
time but certainly you know getting uh
if if depending on your insurance
situation the dental or the the Eye Care
seems like a really great thing that's
available to many people
yeah yeah all right well Dylan thank you
for the call
one little bit of irony uh my last call
was about water scarcity now look at
look at we're swimming down I know yeah
it's water everywhere
well thanks a lot for uh for talking to
me I appreciate it all right there is
Dylan from Tijuana and a great call with
which to conclude today's Town Hall we
will have more Town Halls we will have
more streams we will have all of it
ladies and gentlemen coming very soon it
is great to be back to streaming it is
great to be back in general the new
studio is coming the children's book is
coming everything everything is
happening I will be on the Lex Friedman
show soon I will be on the Patrick Bet
David show soon I will be on with
Anthony pompliano very soon uh and we
will talk to everybody very soon thanks
for being here